- C'est un atelier de travail
pas comme les autres.
LINDA COLLETTE, éducatrice
spécialisée, CIUSSS, Mllll
- L'atelier Champ d'Eau a été
conçu pour répondre aux besoins
de personnes déficientes
intellectuelles avec un trouble
envahissant duopopopoppement,
mais qui présente aussi des
troubles graves de comportement.
ERIC LAFORGE, chef réadaptation
contexte travail, CIUSSS, MTL
- Leurs besosososont tellement
grands, qu'il n'y a pas d'autres
endroits, même dans les milieux
communautaires ne pourrait
pas les accueillir. Donc, à ce
ààà, soit qu'ils restent
dans leur famille et ça devient
très lourd pour leur famille,
parce que nous, ils viennent
ici le jour, ou soit ils restent
dans leurs ressources.
- C'est de mettre en place
des aménagements qui vont faire
en sorte que bien, ils vont être
calmes, ils vont être bien.
Puis là, on entend pas de b
Et pourtant il y a des usagers
qui ont des troubles
de comportement,
qui viennent d'arriver.
- Il y en a pas une soixantaine.
- Avec l'aide des intervenantes,
Nadia arrive à maintenir
sa cadence de travail. Trier
les étiquettes destinées à des
emballages de fromage en étant
entourée de choses qui
la calme et la rassure.
- Je m'attache vite, mais c'est
ça le problème, je m'attachetete
à me détacher.
- Avant la rénovation, ce qu'il
faut comprendre, c'est que
l'atelier, la clientèle était
moins lourde, si on peut dire
ainsi. Puis c'était vraiment
un atelier, comme une usine,
une shop, mais ça ne répondait
plus du tout, là. Il y avait
trop de bruit, il y avait trop
de stimuli et nos usagers, bien
se désorganisaient, faisaient
des crises. Ce n'était pas...
un moment donné, ça ne devenait,
ni pour nos employés.
- (Chuchotement): Comment
vas tu? Je sais que jetetetetet.
- Les salles d'apaisement,
on les utilise toujours
en prévention, donc c'est
à l'horaire de l'usager.
- Autrefois, on avait, à tous
les jours, on avait un ou deux
usagers qui étaient en crise.
Puis maintenant, il y en a plus.
- Les eseseseseseses tables
peuvent résister à presque 600
livres, fait qu'ils ne peuvent
pas être détruits.
- Les immenses ballons qui
traînent dans les couloirs sont
n
au besoin. Tout est pensé pour
préserver le calme et prévenir
l'agitation.
- Il y a même des petitsatatatai
l'usager, à un moment donné, a
besoin qu'on réduise les stimuli
ou même nous, on juge qu'il
aurait besoin de s'apaiser
un peu plus. On va utiliser
le gradateur.
- Christian, tu fais ça comme
un champion.
- Des cubicules individuels,
pas de couleurs vives et on
favorise les pictogrammes
adaptés aux besoins
des personnes autistes.
Qu'eababababababababriques?
Des étiquettes, des contrats
de travail, des lavettes,
des broches, des étiquettes,s,ss
tout ça.
- Les travaux ont été long,
mais depuis l'ouverture
de l'atelier rénové en janvier,
c'est le jour et la nuit.
Il y a l'aménagement des lieux,
bien sûr, mais aussi
les employés, leur nombre,
leur rôle et leur expertise.
- Du personnel, c'est
des éducateurs spécialisés.
Un ratio d'à peu près un pourtrn
qui sont formés et des
intervenants qui travaillent
en prévention. Parce que
ce qu'on veut, c'est prévenir
l'apparition du trouble de
comportement. On ne veut pas des
fiers à bras le sept, ce ne sont
pas... même si vous allez voir,
ils ont des bons gabarits,
mais ce sont des agents au même
titre que nous. Ils ont un jeu,
ils ont un rôle à jouer dans
l'intervention et leur rôle est
important parce que c'est aussi
un rôle d'apaisement. Ils sont
là pour donner le "high five",
pour encourager.
- Le CIUSSS du Centre-Sud
de l'île de Montréal a choisi
de faire ce qu'il faut pour t ts
qui demandent beaucoup
d'encadrement.
- Les usagers vont devenir
ce qu'ils voient dans mon regard
et quand ils me regardent,
je veux qu'ils voient que
je crois en ce qu'ils sont
capables d'accomplir,
parce qu'ils sont capables
de grandes choses, avec
les moyens qu'ils ont.
- Ici Anne-Louise Dépatie,
Radio-Canada. Montréal.